i hate intros fire force season one
episode one
we kick things off with a quick look on
a train where a man
suddenly explodes he turns into some
fire entity known as an
infernal that exits the train but
luckily the main character
shinra kusakabe is there waiting with
open arms to greet him
turns out he doesn't have to do anything
as fire force company 8 shows up to
address the entity
a prayer is said by the sister and the
man is put to rest by the fire force
the sister in the group is nearly
crushed forcing shinra to take action
with powers that he has in order to save
her he then introduces himself to them
as
their new third generation fire soldier
they meet up at special fire cathedral 8
where the team is stationed this is
where we get the official introduction
of eighth company
starting with the captain of the company
akitaru obi
sitting in on their meeting is the
uptight takahisa hinawa who is second in
command to ob
while they're talking we learned that
when sheen refuels tense he has an
involuntary
reaction forcing him to smile shinra
says that he joined to be a hero but
there is a story that has earned him
quite the opposite title of the devil we
get some early fan service to properly
introduce the girls of the team
there is maki jose who is a second
generation fire soldier and a bit of a
romantic
second is iris a sister originating from
the holy soul temple
they go over some backstory on the world
saying that one day people started to
spontaneously combust becoming what is
known as
infernals infernals lose all sense of
themselves and run
rampant until they die in order to put
an infernal to rest you have to strike
their core which is where their heart
once was
that's where the fire force comes into
play tasked with putting the infernal
souls to rest as well as protecting all
the people nearby
their second objective is to find out
what exactly is causing the spontaneous
combustion and how to put an
end to it later on we get a short
flashback of when shinro was a boy with
his mom who he appeared to love
after some incident we see his grandma
labeling him devil and refusing to take
him in
saying that he was responsible for
something back to the present where the
team goes to answer their first call
with shinra
inside their special armored fire engine
codenamed matchbox
they head to a factory where the owner's
wife had turned infernal
monkey goes to clear a path but when she
does it results in an explosion that
hurls shinra into a metal pipe
this prompts another flashback to
shinra's mom being consumed by a fire
and telling him to run away in the
aftermath everybody starts saying that
he was the one responsible with
absolutely no proof
seems like a fun way to handle a child's
grief he also had a younger brother
sho who was burned so badly that they
couldn't even find his bones
inside the flames he saw something else
though some entity that wasn't his mom
or
show and now he is determined to find
that entity assuming that it was the one
that caused the fire
when it comes to they are face to face
with the infernal
as they engage shinra finds an opening
to use his power and attack the infernal
killing it with one kick
episode ii in the opening scene we see a
new face joining 8th company and arthur
boyle who is another 3rd generation fire
soldier like shinra
we also learn from obi that shinra and
arthur are going to be participating in
the rookie fire soldier games
when shinra learns that the new recruit
is arthur he isn't too happy because
apparently the two have some sort of
history
over to maki and iris that teach us
third generation fire soldiers can start
fires on their own while
second generation fire soldiers can
manipulate fire but can't create it
arthur and shinra suddenly bust in on
their talk ready to fight one another we
learned that the two had gone to
training together
arthur had taken on the title of knight
and shinra always thought the title of
hero was cooler so the two have never
seen eye to eye ever since then hinawa
comes in and orders maki to spar with
both shinra and
arthur at the same time turns out she's
kind of a badass and man handles both of
them forcing them to concede they go
over all the equipment at their disposal
before heading to their next call
a father had just went infernal and the
mother just went infernal
also two years ago leaving the daughter
all by herself
shinra and arthur are then reprimanded
by obi for showing their weapons in
front of the daughter because
essentially they're about to kill her
dad so it's a bit insensitive
someone passing by does something to the
flame causing it to have a strange
reaction which refocuses the team on
their mission
when they come inside the father is
sitting calmly at the table
even though he's maintaining his
composure everybody assumes that the
infernals are in constant pain so arthur
puts him to rest
after he's dead the bystander who had
manipulated the fire before
uses some sort of ash to attack the team
collapsing the building on top of them
and nearly crushing obi we get our first
look at the culprit
joker who appears to want to target them
again
episode 3 joker meets up with a man
named victor who was the one responsible
for giving joker the ash that allowed
him to attack
the fire force they both seem to have
taken an interest in the eighth company
for some reason collecting a lot of
information on them now we're gonna hop
on over to the rookie fire soldier games
where shinra comes across
the new front runner in waifu candidates
tamaki
katatsu shinra then notices a man nearby
who looks just like the guy that
responded to the call when he had lost
his mom as a kid
he approaches the man and we are
introduced to leonard burns the captain
of fire forces first company
when shinra introduces himself and says
he wants to talk about the fire that
happened 12 years ago
leonard seems to have a cold reaction
and then dips when he finally catches up
to burns he just says that he can't
remember the fire leading shinra to
believe that he's hiding something the
rookies are then tasked with entering a
simulated fire scene rescuing anyone
inside and being the first to get to the
infernal actor
shinra uses his abilities to get to the
top floor in hopes of gaining a lead but
when he gets inside he comes face to
face with
joker after a little skirmish joker
tells him that his little brother sho
is still alive joker then says there is
some sort of corruption going on in the
fire force so he wants shinra to join
him and become a real devil
arthur and tamaki then come across joker
and shinra but think it's a part of the
games so they attack joker instead of
getting help
joker uses his mystery ash to cause an
explosion covering his escape while
shinra is forced to get everybody to
safety
later on shinra goes to obi to ask him
about the possibility of there being
corruption in the fire force
this is where we get some more backstory
on how the fire force operates
there are three factions that make up
the fire force the holy soul temple the
tokyo armed forces and the fire defense
agency
each company answers to different
factions with the first company
answering to the temple
the second company answers to the tokyo
armed forces
however the third and fifth companies
answer to hajima industries who is
responsible for making a lot of fire
force's weapons
and tools the fire force companies see
each other as
rivals and keep what knowledge they gain
to themselves
obi's eighth company was strong armed
into existence by an unknown group with
the purpose of
investigating companies one through
seven in order to find out the truth
about human combustion
obi believes that someone in the fire
force should already know what's causing
the infernals to appear and he wants
them to reveal it to save lives
ye episode 4. the substance that joker
has been using was analyzed and revealed
to be
infernal ashes this essentially means
that joker is using the remains of the
dead to create explosives
we then get a look at a former
firefighter named miyamoto who had
killed four people for the fun of it
and is now on trial he is declared not
guilty even though he clearly is and
then he bursts into flames
he turns into an infernal but seems to
be coherent still and
attacks the judge even though he had
just declared him innocent
we then get a quick scene of fifth
company's sadist captain hibana
saying that she wants to study miyamoto
because he still has a sense of self
everyone shows up to fight miyamoto but
he starts to run so shinra is ordered to
chase him because he's the only one fast
enough to keep up shanera quickly
subdues him but then the fifth company
steps in
and restrains miyamoto instead of
killing him when shinra tries saying
that the eighth company is taking care
of this he is attacked and pinned by the
captain and her company
shinra breaks free and is ready to fight
the entire company when the others show
up putting an end to the conflict
even though they're an eighth company's
district fifth company wants to take
miyamoto because they have a research
team that is able to study the sentient
infernal
since eighth company is new and doesn't
have a research team obi agrees as long
as they share the results of the study
fifth company's toro kishiri a third
generation fire soldier stirs things up
a bit insulting obi but then gets put in
his place by maki in the last scene
episode 5. fifth company is clearly not
to be trusted and since 8th company is
also tasked with finding corrupt members
in the other companies they do some
digging
they learned that hibana had been
conducting illegal experiments on
infernals and then used the findings to
climb her way to captain
one night sister iris goes missing and
we see that she went to meet with hibana
the two appear to be childhood friends
as they grew up orphans together she now
appears to hate the sisters and the
church saying that there is no god and
iris is stupid for believing there is
she then takes iris hostage to lure out
eighth company for a fight
eighth company shows up and attacks the
base to get iris back
arthur ends up running into the stud
known as conehead who says that he can't
have him snooping around their base
joining him is miyamoto who has been
administered a special drug that boosts
his firepower
meanwhile maki and hinawa are attacked
by the [ __ ] toru and his explosive
bubble gum
he now uses his power to bend the
bullets around the corner where toru is
hiding and slows them down enough to
knock him unconscious
back on over to arthur who was losing
because he's kind of stupid and realized
that his sword was in his off hand
i feel like that's something you'd
realize right away but once he makes
that correction he quickly wins
episode 6 shinra shows up to fight
hibana and save iris but hibana uses
heat syncope causing him to have vertigo
we then learned that everyone at the
covent where hibana iris and other
orphans were raised was engulfed in fire
they all ended up dying except for
hibana and iris which is when hibana
gave up on god and became kind of
[ __ ] crazy
anyways managing to fight through the
vertigo shinra gets to hibana and decks
the [ __ ] in the face knocking her
unconscious
when she wakes up i guess she realized
that what she did was wrong so she makes
up with shinra and iris
after the credits they decide to tell
everyone in the fifth that the attack
was a part of a training drill in
cooperation with the eighth
we also learned in the last scene that
hibana is so cooperative now because
she's thirsty as [ __ ] for shinra and his
sinister smile
yeah episode seven we get a quick scene
introducing three new faces at the first
company's cathedral and who young lee
rekha hoshimiya and kareem lom who all
answer to burns
meanwhile the fifth and eighth companies
have a party to show that there's no
hard feelings between the two hibana
goes on to share all of her information
with obi as well they had learned that
somebody out there is creating
artificial infernals but that doesn't
mean that every spontaneous combustion
is the result of this
the suspected artificial infernos all
had something in common they were first
sighted near shinjuku ward which is
first company's territory they plan to
use the rookie training reassignment
system to have shinra and arthur
infiltrate first company along with the
[ __ ] from fifth company tohru one
other rookie was brought in from second
company in the new face takaru noto to
tag along as
well ho yon lee kareem and rekka are
tasked with looking after the rookies
shortly after arriving shinra challenges
burns to a sparring match and if he wins
he gets to ask them a question
all of the rookies have to participate
in the sparring and noto is forced to go
first
against rekka we learned that noto
doesn't like flames and try joining the
fire force to learn how to control them
so he inadvertently attacks
rekka which he dodges most of the
fighting is just filler content to show
off everybody's abilities although we
also do see that noto falls in love with
tamaki which let's be honest is
completely understandable
burns then ordered shinra and arthur to
fight him at the same time we see that
both of their attacks do [ __ ] off for
damage even when arthur's excalibur
which is a plasma sword makes direct
contact with burns he then defeats both
of them with one shot ending the
sparring in the last scene
episode 8 using kibana's research obi
learns that the artificial infernals
were created using some sort of bug that
forced its way into the human's heart
everyone responds to a mass combustion
call where five victims have turned to
infernals
shinra and arthur are ordered to wait
nearby but they see a man get infected
with one of the bugs turning him into an
infernal also
they rush after the culprit responsible
and run into rucka and kareem who were
nearby but nothing comes from it once
back they go to investigate kareem's
room they find one of the insects in his
desk but then he reveals that he is
trying to find the culprit just like
them
kareem suspects that rekka is
responsible since he was the only one
nearby
hop on over to rekka and tamaki who
round up some kids so that he can
perform
a prayer that prevents them from
becoming infernals because tamaki wanted
to be present for the prayer he then
knocks her out and attacks the mother
accompanying the children turning her
into an infernal using one of the bugs
and kills her
rekka is apparently creating infernals
to find someone who can host the pilot
light tamaki comes too just in time to
get her ass kicked by rekka again
he then targets one of the kids
infecting him with another bug as well
luckily this kid doesn't turn into an
inferno because he just so happened to
be compatible
tamaki uses her powers to send up a
signal which shinra sees and he comes to
save her just before she is killed by
rekka
episode 9. even after shinra smashed his
head into the ground rekka is still
up and fighting one of rekka's bugs
seems to be reacting to shinra's fire
and rekka says that it's trying to get
back to his flames
apparently shinra is the third person
that the evangelist has been searching
for
because he has an undefiled flame called
the adola burst
another scrimmage breaks out and again
sheen ruins when asked what his goal is
rekka explains that followers of the
evangelist are trying to set the entire
world of flame and turn it into a second
son
rekka also says that he was planning on
taking the children to become followers
of the evangelist as
well this makes sheener think it's
possible that's what happened to his
little brother
kareem steps in and puts an end to the
fight when he freezes rekka the original
plan was to defrost the wreck a popsicle
to get some answers from him but then he
is shot by an unknown archer her
and another member are in white robes
which will later mark them as being a
part of the white clad
a group led by the evangelist she begins
firing on the others as well and ho
young lee gets his arm blown off while
saving kareem
they use smoke and ice to obstruct the
archer's view forcing them to retreat
kareem then volunteers first company to
help 8th company in finding the
evangelist and bringing them to justice
we also learned that tamaki has been put
on suspension because of the incident so
8th company has taken her in
until her suspension is over yep so 10.
all of the company's captains are
summoned to meet at the imperial throne
room in order to discuss the evangelist
group that is now known
as the conference is about to get
underway we get an official introduction
of all of the company's captains
we already know first company's captain
in leonard burns
second company is gustav honda third
company dr
giovanni fourth company so ichiro hager
fifth company's crazy [ __ ] turned
shinra simp sixth company kayoko huang
seventh companies benny marushimon who's
supposed to be the strongest soldier in
the entire fire force
and of course eighth company's captain
good guy ob leading the meeting is the
decrepitly old emperor raffles iii
before the meeting even starts shimon
makes a scene saying that he doesn't
answer to their god and then storms out
after that they discuss the fact that
shinra has an edola burst
the emperor explains that the edola
burst is an unsolid pure flame
it's said to be the primordial flame and
the spark that the god soul used when
creating the world we also learn about
the amaterasu which is the perpetual
thermal energy plant providing all of
the energy to the entire tokyo empire
the amadorasu is ran by a flame that is
no more or less than an idola burst as
well the evangelists are seeking the
edola burst flames and it's likely that
they'll come for shinra
everyone starts to head back except for
shinra who wanted to go see the
rasu up close while he's there he's
approached by his old pal joker
as a reward for exposing rekka joker
gives him some more information
he tells him that shinra's brother shoku
sakabe is the commander of the knights
of the ashen flame which is a part of
the white clad
later on at dinner shinra fills eighth
company and on joker's appearance and
the possibility of his brother working
with the white clad
episode 11. we get the 8th company's
origin story in the form of a flashback
one of hinawa's friends
named tojo had ended up turning into an
infernal right in front of him
in tojo's last moments he was begging he
now want to kill him but he couldn't do
it a team of soldiers then busts in
and kills tojo instead later on he meets
up with obie who was just a normal
firefighter at the time
the two of them worked together to put
an infernal to rest because the company
that was supposed to be taking care of
it was busy with another one
obi decides that he's gonna make his own
fire force company and after two years
of hard work he finally succeeds
hiring hinawa in the process they needed
some new talent so he now
brought in maki who he knew from his
time in the tokyo armed forces
back to the present where they
investigate the eighth company's very
first call
the infernal in the incident had white
clothes on and they recovered a red
cross from him as well
it seemed like the business he worked
for was in a hurry to retrieve this and
when they looked up that business it was
in seventh company's jurisdiction
hop on over to seventh company where we
meet the two lolly twins in the company
hikage and hinata the last member is a
third generation fire soldier named
sagamia conroe eighth company shows up
unexpectedly to search the jurisdiction
in an attempt to find the evangelist
shortly after their arrival everyone is
alerted to another infernal that has
been spotted so captain shimon jumps
into action
we learned that he is a compound fire
soldier having both
second and third generation powers this
of course means that he can create his
own fire and simultaneously control it
the man who had turned into an infernal
was an old friend of shinmon so he kills
it without a fight in the last scene
[Music]
episode 12. both 7th and 8th companies
worked to repair the buildings that shin
moon had damaged as a tribute to the
infernal
after seeing how kind the eighth company
is shin moon comes around to helping
with their investigation
we learned that conroe was affected by
tephrosis which is when a third
generation keeps using their power even
after overheating and burning themselves
in the process
shainra was sent by obi to go request
another meeting with shimon
in an alley when he goes there he sees
two evangelist members who look exactly
like
obi and hinawa they talk about how they
are the ones responsible for turning
shimon's friend into an infernal and
plan to destroy the entire district
thinking eighth company is in on it he
picks a fight with all of them
because he's the strongest soldier in
all of the fire force nobody can keep up
with him
obie despite not having any powers at
all is the only one that can manage to
land a shot on him which makes shimon
get serious
it seems like he's charging up a
powerful attack but before he can launch
it conroe steps in and calms him down
enough to hear them out they explained
that it wasn't
them so shimon goes to investigate what
actually happened
while waiting for him to return we get
the story of how conroe got so injured
after numerous people went infernal
conroe and shimon were at their limits
and confronted with some sort of demon
infernal conroe forces shimon out of the
fight knocking him unconscious in the
process and then pushes himself past his
limits to defeat the infernal the
repercussions of his powers left him
severely wounded and now he can't use
his powers without making his wounds
worse i'm gonna be doing part two and
you can find that in the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the fire force recaps in
the playlist on the right side you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing i hate more
than intros is outros